remember I said that we are leaving off
some kinds of applications of series and
sequences to later okay now at the
moment we just kind of crossing that
that blurry line this is the kind of
thing we're talking about right the GP
is not the question the GP features in
the question it's one aspect on right
and then you have to answer stuff around
that so if this feels like closes like a
lot of extra stuff because it is a lot
of extra stuff and we will learn will do
with it like formally next to you but
this particular point that I just wrote
down it's the line before I have my
formula appear I try to make a note
about market because in some HSCs but
not others and accordingly in some
internal exams and not others this
particular statement here attract one
mark okay one mark out of safe three
marks for a question like this maybe
four depending on how hard the situation
is to interpret and how hard the numbers
are ya ok so now generally speaking
Abner sure it's not shy of having to say
it ok um I actually need to do with
formal test the reason why is because
you've done so much work up here that is
kind of like oh look the series has been
building like you yourself is doing the
terms and you've done the patent
remember that you did a1 a2 a3 so in
some ways that's sufficient however this
part here right many students will skip
it and just go straight to this language
I think you already have let's see one
okay ah many students will skip that
line you know it takes time to write and
so on and we'll be you know no worse off
okay because honestly to write this kind
of implies that I understand [ __ ] do
you see that like where does this come
from it comes to the fact it must be a
GP and I have like character for
character protocol for protocol
substitute everything into that formula
okay however I'm going to encourage you
to do this not just because sometimes it
gets that back by the way the reason why
it sometimes does and sometimes it
doesn't depends on two things number on
the complexity question and also the
quality of the cohort answering the
question so if we have a really strong
current going through for instance and
the only thing that really distinguishes
responses between the stronger ones are
the weaker ones is the inclusion of a
line like this if that's the only thing
that we've assessed that right we will
put my mark because it helps us separate
out the cohort but often we don't need
to do that kind of depends on the
question depends on the year when I
found this out the first time it sort of
drove me mad what what do you mean the
rulebook is changing all the time that's
frustrating it's not it's just the fact
that like in the real world we sometimes
have to say yeah we're okay with this
margin of error other times we're okay
with this module ground that's just real
life okay so I'm going to state it
there's one other reason it helps you
make sure you get this line right yeah
um this is about as standard as it gets
in that you start with that is your
first term the ratio is very easy to see
it's just the number as opposed to say
like a log or a trig function or
something like that and also the notice
em but just as many times you'll see
something which is more complicated a
will be something we in our will be
harder to identify and rather than n
terms that I be at minus one and plus 1
or n or two or 2m you've got to be
really careful and so stadia explicitly
gets a big thumbs up from me I do it and
I've been doing for you
okay no I've got that other way I could
do a little bit to simplify this yeah
what shall I do 5,000 times 10
okay so he are just be careful this is a
denominator yeah so this is dividing by
0.05 what is the 0.05 as a fraction it's
5 100 which is one of 20 right so how
many girls been what I'm 20 or the
denominator here is really the same as x
20 do you agree with that so I'm just
going to simplify this just on the book
UK without you see I'm just 50 10 to 100
right so 1.5 and minus 1 okay so we
wanted to find how many people in total
have been turn whenever the tab is
called the star with a in the first six
years so I want n equals six I actually
don't my birth tons yeah i want i want
each show okay now that's one so i can
get that that's am i can put in six to
get a six right so that's just some
calculator work and I think you'll find
you get this
oh wow good point
now we talked about that a second i'll
just write down this number ok now it's
a point which I'm deliberately going to
miss now that I just want to point out
we do have like a fraction of a person
why don't we refraction of a person it's
a king why is that child everything so
as a child it's like because look at my
way I'm about how about point 5 6 40 in
person right the reason why is built
right into the question right what's the
rate at which this are the population
the audience is going it's five percent
at five percent now five percent is fine
when you got big round numbers okay but
fairly quickly you do not have big round
numbers so when you get five percent you
can have these decimals hanging around
okay okay now we will talk about like
the rounding of this thing because it's
it's own separate idea where its
population versus when it's money etc
okay um it's enough of an idea that
we're actually going to dig into it a
little further but for now just going to
leave it packed i'm just going to round
it i'm just going to wrap it is giving
me an approximation yeah this formula is
thing here doesn't give me an exactly
but then again neither there's five
percent right like five percent itself
has to be an approximation can you see
that like if for example from one year i
had five thousand and seven people to
the next year I have you know 6412 okay
unless I've been extraordinarily lucky
at all that's a multiple of three but
for the worst number of ego um unless
you're extraordinarily lucky that will
not be a whole digit whole number
percent right so you're going to
approximate I'm guessing that's one for
five percent is ok so there are
approximations at some point in some
ways all the way through okay so I'm
going to populate
will do with it again what we do with
money that's where it's really
deployment there's a six normally at
this point i would now do the same
process all the way for B sub M ok but
being that I think you understand the
process I'm just going to jump straight
to what I would get here ok so this is a
sudden what's the same and what's
different about be subject yeah ok now i
can think of it in terms of like well
are you talking about like these sides
in here ok i could think well there's
instead of minus that appears here for a
growing audience maybe it's a plus that
appears for a shrinking audience ok the
problem with that is what happens as you
start to build b1 and b2 and b3 let me
help you okay i'm going to do this in
the short form i would go back like i
said to be one but let me show you what
the first year for the declining show
but is still gonna be 5,000 okay but
when i do to you the next year a five
percent drop in the size of the audience
means that it's not going to be one
point 05 at all that's the ratio because
waiting the point if I've come from
again it's it's one plus five percent
right there's actually two pieces there
now what I want is not one plus five
percent but 1 minus right so it'll be
not point 05 but 0.95 you see that it's
shrinking this thing is getting small
often okay the same way the subsequent
year after that the third year it will
shrink again right that's why I've got
that factor too and then I'm going to go
all the way whoops did 5,000 and what
will be my end year because it's the F
partial sign
good there's the eighth term its index
SN minus one okay of that I would say if
I went in such a hurry and have other
questions to go onto I would say this is
a GP after i take my factor of 1000 5000
app i'll say our a is one our is 0.95
and it still has em terms i would
usually state that on the basis of that
i can launch into my own so 5,000 now
pause remember we said there are two
forms of the same formula right so we
said this we use in this case we use
this form but in a second I values the
other four right what was the other form
again what differs yeah good fantastic
so oh yeah i've multiplied the top and
bottom that he branded unidentified
negative 1 which is switched everything
around okay now why am i choosing the
second form for this one even though
it's in the same question why am i doing
that facade in between minus one good
and so this value of our right 0.95 if I
chuck it in here I get a negative on the
denominator there's nothing wrong with
that don't get the same odds on it's
just don't tend to like know you'll
enjoy it I'm have to cancel anyway so
might as well just saved myself the
trouble and use this guy right so I'm
going to go a times 1 minus R to the N
divided by 1 minus ah
are you comfortable with that so it's
just same thing just in a different form
I can evaluate it's just like I did
before I'm still getting sent to
nominate our anti right it still 0.05
which is exactly the same as multiplying
by 20 all right so I'm still going to
get my 100,000
through
happy with that now it's pretty trivial
really to pop six into that but you'll
get a number out which I'm just going to
go straight to my approximation which I
already calculated which is this okay so
what have we worked out this is the sum
of all the people in one show for six
years and all the people in the other
okay and that was a lot of work just to
get two numbers at the end ok but this
amount of work is going to save us work
for later on because we've got Part B
and Part C going through